it's really interesting I've been
talking to a lot of people about this
because I'm interested in different
peoples take on the show this year I'm
really intrigued by it because as soon
as the list of artists was announced I
was really excited because I'm a big fan
of a lot of the artists in the show and
I think they're just from the list list
of names it evoked a very particular
sort of direction I think even though
there wasn't a theme and art the the
curators have been really articulate
about it too they talk about a less
pneus and a sort of modesty in the work
that I think we haven't seen before
which is certainly true in my work I
think if you compare it's interesting in
a way just to compare the project that
was in the sculpture court for the last
biennial the Peace Tower and in my
project that's there now you know one
that was about the war and this one I
mean I suppose in particular you could
say is about the environment in some way
but I really didn't want to do a project
that was a monumental that was an object
that occupied the space or even
dominated it I really wanted to do a
very quiet project that's sort of woven
self into the space and and really was
um took a backseat to it and I think I
think a lot of the work in the show is
with very modest materials and it
doesn't and for the most part it's the
work isn't very highly produced and it
tends to be I mean I think the best of
the work really
tends to be quite modest in that regard
I suppose I really like Jedediah Caesar
has a really phenomenal huge colossal
block of rainbow colored resin that is
on I don't know I think it might be in
the fourth floor but as part of my
project we're doing animal movements to
the museum all 12 animals are being
performed by a dancer every week so one
of the dance the the score of the the
mason bee is actually performed around
this piece coincidentally and he told me
where he told a friend of mine that um
while he was making the piece bees kept
getting attracted to it and stuck in it
so there's all these bees in there so
strangely enough our be movements are
having right around that piece I know um
Stein yaqaan and Harry dodge are French
from Los Angeles that have this
wonderful video in the show I think
that's become really popular there's a
performance in this in this biennial and
I think you know the strange thing about
performances you can't you can't walk
through the Whitney Museum and pass
judgment on the exhibition is easily
because it's it's wrapped up in all this
time based work that you need to spend
time with and that you need to go and
experience separately so I think there's
a lot of work happening at museum and at
the Armory that you won't be able to see
all at once for example there's a
performance this tuesday that i'm going
to buy a couple from la called lucky
dragons and their work is very
interactive and involves the group
creation of sound and music together as
a collaborative
then I'm looking for two